for weeks the bite administration told
us that a drone strike had killed a
group of isis-k terrorists whatever that
is
in kabul and there were secondary
explosions that proved they were suicide
bombers
but they were lying forced by the new
york times to admit it they've now
conceded they killed a number of
innocent people including children
here's the interesting part mistakes
happen
but in this case no one in the pentagon
has been punished for this mistake or
for lying about it we thought it'd be
interesting to see what tulsi gabbard
thinks about this she's a former member
of congress from hawaii she served in
iraq as a member of the hawaii army
national guard she's still serving the
country in the military she joins us
tonight congresswoman thanks so much for
coming on
so you get to lie i mean this will not
shock you because you've seen it so much
but
you get to lie about the loss of human
life you get caught and nothing happens
to you what kind of system is that
i mean this kind of accountability is
critical i want to point out first that
any time there are civilian casualties
in war it is tragic and terrible
war is a terrible thing and and i think
it's important for the american people
to understand that islamist jihadists
are continuing to wage war against us
and the islamist ideology not the same
as the religion of islam but this
islamist
ideology which is a political ideology
that inspired the terrorist attacks on
our country on 9 11 uh is is
the greatest threat that we're facing
right now in this country in the world
it is the foundation of governance of
so-called islamic countries like turkey
and iran and
saudi arabia and pakistan
and it's what's behind the
discriminatory policies that they have
in these countries against christians uh
hindus buddhists atheists and others
so as long as these islamist jihadists
are waging war against us
we have to work to defeat them
militarily and ideologically and
militarily we have two choices in how we
do that number one we can continue to
invade and occupy in nation-building
countries around the world just as we
did in afghanistan at great cost
number two we can take a targeted
approach using airstrikes using our
special forces to go in and go after
these terrorist cells
the reality is that the cost
the cost of the american people the cost
to our troops the cost to civilians will
be far less if we take this very
targeted approach to go after these
jihadist terrorist cells than if we
continue making the very same mistakes
that we saw in afghanistan and other
parts of the world of invasion
occupation and nation building
so in order to do that or to affect any
successful military strategy you have to
have competent people running things and
doesn't competence require honesty and
accountability and that's what i see
missing here it's like you can't you're
not allowed to lie to the public which
employs you are you
the american people deserve honesty they
deserve leaders who lead with integrity
and not those who shy away from their
own responsibilities to the american
people or look for a lower ranking fall
guy to take the hit the american people
deserve strong leadership that looks out
for their best interests and the best
interests of our country
when was the last time a general officer
or someone you know pentagon
level commander
in the u.s military
was punished for a mistake or is it it's
always the corporals lieutenants the
captains
that's that's a really good question
tucker and i can tell you from having
just come off of active duty having just
come back from a deployment uh to africa
there it's a common frustration
uh among service members when it is
someone of a lower rank who takes the
hit for decisions
and policies that were made far above
their level it's so dishonorable that
that whole way of governing anything not
just the military it's not leadership no
it's not leadership at all cowardice
tells you gabbard welcome back thanks so
much
thanks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else